even though the interest rates have gone
up there still is a dramatic inventory
shortage in real estate in almost every
city
in order for prices of anything to come
down
Supply demand curves have to shift
meaning that the supply has to be much
higher than the demand
but when there is the opposite a
shortage
versus a glut in the market when there's
a shortage prices go up
so if you want to cause the prices on
something to go up make it scarce
make it be a shortage I mean there is a
shortage of real estate and so the the
opposite of prices tanking everybody's
oh it's all going to go away it's all
going to be another front two thousand
and we kept saying no it's not it's not
going to bust it's not going to bust we
said it is going to slow down and we
said if you're going to sell a house
you're going to have to actually clean
it up